A lot of the narrative, we saw
that in theheadlines, has been,
"It's going to do the writing for kids.
Kids are not going to learnto write."
But we are showing that there's ways
that the AI doesn't write for you,
it writes withyou.
You can say, “I want to write a horror story,”
and it says,
"Ooh, a horror story,how
spine-tingling and thrilling.
Let's dive into the world of eerie
shadows and chillingmysteries."
And this is an activity where
the student will write two sentences,
and thenthe AI will write two sentences.
And so they collaborate together on a story.
The studentwrites, "Beatrice was
a misunderstood ghost.
She wanted to make friends but
kept scaring themby accident."
And the AI says, "Poor Beatrice, a lonely
spirit yearning for companionship.
Oneday she stumbled upon an
old abandoned mansion," etc.
I encourage you all to hopefully one
day try this. This is surprisingly fun.
And we think this is just the very tip
ofthe iceberg of where this can actually go.